there were people from all walks of
French life teachers students and
lawyers joint transport and health
workers and central Paris part of a
nationwide strike protesting against the
government's plans to reform the pension
system they fear the changes would force
them to work for more years and reduce
their payouts we are here to try and
preserve our pension system which is one
of the best in Europe and we don't want
to go backwards
macrons reforms are destroying French
society it looks like we'll have to
retire even later that will have even
less money in our pension the
demonstration was mainly peaceful but
there were some clashes between police
and so-called black bloc anarchist
protesters more than 6000 police
officers were deployed in the city this
police union spokesperson said many of
them would have wanted to join the
strike yes it's difficult for us the
strike caused major disruption across
the city there was little public
transport and most schools were shut
even the eiffel tower was forced to
close the French president says the
pension system needs to be streamlined
to make it fairer and save public money
the strikes are a major test for
Emmanuel macron because he made
reforming the pension system one of his
campaign promises so if he gives in to
the protesters and scraps his reform it
will be a political failure but so far
the French president is showing no sign
of backing down this analyst says macro
has a track record of controversial
reforms since the beginning of its
mandate the government has passed
several reforms that many would have
believed would be almost impossible but
they managed to push them through
despite the challenges and risk macro
may not want to make concessions but if
the disruption continues
may have to rethink although most people
are expected to return to work this week
some transport workers say they won't
give up their fight and will continue to
strike
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Paris